and Godot a free and open source game
engine capable of building high quality
2D and 3D games it was created in 2007
in Argentina and open sourced in 2014
like Unity it provides an editor that
allows you to create visualize and
program the behavior of game objects
however Godot weighs in at just 35
megabytes while providing a full feature
developer experience that's approachable
to beginners game code can be written in
C sharp C plus plus or a purpose-built
language called GD script it feels like
a cross between typescript and Python
and dramatically reduces the amount of
complexity and boilerplate when coding
game scripts to create a game you start
with a scene which itself contains a
tree of nodes nodes are like building
blocks that can be assigned as the child
of another node to control the
appearance and behavior of objects in
the scene any node can have a script
attached to it allowing you to write
code that updates the object for every
frame in the game Loop you can then save
the scene to disk and use it within
other scenes when your awesome game is
complete it can be exported with a
single click to desktop web and mobile
platforms or two consoles like Nintendo
switch PS4 and Xbox via third-party
providers to build your own game right
now download it and create a new project
start with a new 3D scene then add a
static body node to it which is ideal
for things like walls and Floors on its
own it's invisible but we can change
that by adding a collision shape node as
a child choose a shape type on the right
side then modify its actual size by
editing the values directly or by
dragging the Gizmo with the mouse it's
still just a wireframe but we can bring
it to Life by also adding a mesh
instance node a mesh is a collection of
triangles that make 3D shapes look
realistic we can also make the scene
look more realistic by adding a
directional light to it which will cast
Shadows off of other 3D objects now to
add a player to the game we'll create
another scene this time with a kinematic
body as the root which is ideal for
objects that you move around with a
controller give it a collision shape and
mesh then open up the project settings
and go to input map from here we can
create labels like move left and move
right then map the those labels to
multiple different controls like keys on
a keyboard or buttons on a joypad and
now we can write some code by attaching
a script to the root object that moves
the player when these inputs are pressed
create variables with the VAR keyword
with an optional type annotation and
Export them to make them public in the
editor now override the process or
physics process function to calculate a
new position for the player based on the
inputs pressed by the user now go back
to the main scene and add the player
scene as a node also add a camera for
the end user's point of view click play
and you now have the beginning of a real
video game this has been Godot in 100
seconds hit the like button for more
short videos like this thanks for
watching and I will see you in the next
one